hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
trace elements now if you would like a
better understanding of what elements
are please see my other video titled
elements vs. compounds now to understand
what trace elements are first let's talk
briefly about common elements the most
common elements among living organisms
are carbon oxygen hydrogen and nitrogen
in fact these four elements alone are so
common that they make up approximately
96% of all living matter so now that we
know what common elements are lower
trace elements well depending on whether
you are coming at this from a biology
perspective or a chemistry perspective
trace elements has a slightly different
definition from the biology side of
things a trace element is a dietary
element so something that an organism
obtains as a nutrient source a dietary
element needed in very small quantities
these are elements that are essential
for the organism to grow to develop and
to have overall everyday healthy
physiology these include elements like
iodine iron copper zinc and others and
you've probably heard of these elements
especially if you're taking a daily
multivitamin for example some elements
are even added to our food sources for
example iodized salt is table salt that
contains iodine in order to make sure
that humans are eating the necessary
amounts of iodine in their diet now if
you're looking at trace elements from a
chemistry perspective the definition is
still somewhat
alarm in chemistry a trace element is an
element found again in very small
concentrations in some sample so still
we have this situation where it's a very
small part of the overall sample in
general in chemistry the sample in order
for it to be considered a trace element
it needs to be present at concentrations
of less than 100 parts per million for
example but that is it today for trace
elements thanks for watching biology
professor and I hope you learned a lot